I absolutely love these peppers now they
have the most amazing sweet delicious
flavor with a really nice crunchy
texture and the most exciting thing
about the peppers is that they're just
as delicious raw or cooked so identify
the perfect pepper must be smooth and
firm and not a wrinkle in sight now how
to cut the perfect pepper stalk off
pepper down and get the knife start from
the top and slice all the way around
basically we're gonna be slicing around
the seeds look no faffing around like
this little perfect Christmas tree of
seeds and yam got the mess all over your
board and more importantly is twice as
quick discard that now we're gonna cut
it into a julienne flatten the pepper
skin side down onto the board
cuz it's a lot easier to slice through
the pepper and just lift the knife up
and down and basically julienne is a
chef's word for strips these are
absolutely perfect for ascertain and
that's what we're looking for they're
crunchy delicious and more importantly
no seeds beautiful lying there and a
line going across put the point of the
knife in and just push through step on
is the most expensive spice in the world
made from the dried stigma of croak